good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Monday that truly
feels like a Monday because my god do we
have a mountain to climb today so much
to do so much to see so what's wrong
with wait I have to stop singing songs
on the podcast we'll get into that later
in the week hey JX how you turn hey ler
de doing good as you stated it's such a
Monday yuck but it's exciting because
there's so much percolating so much to
discuss we have so much to do today I
think everyone is kind of looking to us
the number one sports podcast in the
world to be like what is going to be
said
today there's not much that can be said
you know
like it's I mean the the like most good
things in life today's episode is going
to be lied because last night was lied
there was so much going on of course
there were two different games two
different teams headed to the Super Bowl
two teams dreams were crushed but then
there's of course the Taylor and Travis
element which not only like were we fed
we feasted yeah we as a culture we
feasted we were full on life last night
they gave us so much to talk about they
really did and of course it's our first
story and I feel like we should just
wait for the stories to get into it
because it's kind of like the only story
like the other four who cares take them
or leave them yeah so we'll get into
that and we'll do a really quick before
the stories catch up yeah this isn't
going to be one of those days where it's
20 minutes till the first story like I
mean well first of all L turn de you
never know like you can't say that until
it's done I know but like I have one
thing on my mind right now you know I
know I know but let's just catch up
quickly how was your weekend how was the
Stockyards how was the rodeo my weekend
was amazing I went to and I kept last
week calling it The Dallas rodeo and I
realized like why that you know rubbed
people the wrong way it's not the Dallas
Rodeo it's the Fort Worth Rodeo and you
would think like the airport is called
Dallas Fort Worth they're literally the
same they could not be more different
these two towns and I've been to Dallas
many times and it's like a mini New York
obviously it's Southern but it's not
like crazy country like no it's like a
Suburban feels like Long Island it's
Urban like it's not it's not that crazy
you know I spent the whole weekend in
Fort Worth very different 30 minutes
outside of Dallas and I had such a blast
it's so country like it's really Texas
you know and we went to the rodeo the
Fort Worth Rodeo and we just spent the
whole weekend in Fort Worth like doing
the things getting hats boots doing the
things you're supposed to do it's such a
blast I first of all love the rodeo
and you know I was given like a little
bit like special access you know I got
to go behind the scen see the Bulls
special treatment you got to meet the
Bulls I did and when I was with you know
the rodeo peeps the the question on
everybody's lips I kept saying I was
like have you seen the longest ride
Jackie they have they have seen the
longest ride and is it an accurate
representation of their profession I
actually do think so and they like it
they like it do they like it as much as
we like it
I mean I don't know if they literally
like remembered every detail of the film
they were like oh yeah I think I've seen
that movie like it doesn't resonate with
them in the way that it resonated with
us it's too much you guys if you haven't
seen the longest ride like you
absolutely have to it's the best romance
movie out there it is the strangest
movie great yeah because it's all about
it's like obviously the longest ride the
bull riding it's about the rodeo the
romance but it also has a lot of Jewish
history yes I remember when I first saw
the movie I was like is this a romantic
comedy or a holocaust movie like it's
kind of a holocaust you I know it sounds
crazy that's why you have to watch can't
describe it you can't put it into words
but that's why it's so good I think
because it has so much depth no and I
heard all weekend about you know the
amazing Jewish community in Fort Worth
you know we got a real nice synagogue
around here like I kind of am obsessed
with Fort Worth I went to the Stockyards
I really I honestly it was one of those
trips where I feel like I didn't get
enough time absorbing the culture you
left wanting more oh and it's really
worth noting I don't believe there is a
town more populated with toasters than
Fort Worth Texas I I you know I love to
travel this great nation and I love to
measure you know the toaster per capita
ratio I have never in my life met more
toasters than I did at Fort Worth and
I'm waiting I need to go visit some more
towns because I don't know if there's a
town more populated but maybe it was
just like the rodeo is very toasty no no
no no they weren't there for the rodeo
like everyone in Fort Worth goes to the
rodeo but they weren't from out of town
they weren't no it was very much like a
local Affair got it got it and it was
amazing like I just had the best time
I'm so excited to be back and you know
Manan godl oh yeah with her big flight
that came home that she made how many
times last week did I say I got on an
earlier flight cuz I love y yada yada so
I got on the earlier flight we're
starting our initial descent into
LaGuardia Airport and the guy's like uh
actually never mind mind our landing
gear is like not fit for icy conditions
so we have to go to the nearest airport
where there's no ice that's Raleigh now
I just want to say like this new trend
where airlines are like you know putting
people on planes that aren't fit to fly
you know we know about the Alaska door
I'm calling out yeah Delta you put me
who the [__] flies to New York in the
middle who the [__] flies to New York in
the middle of January without proper
landing gear like it's really dangerous
and and I didn't feel unsafe because we
had the proper landing gear like we
could have landed in Florida like
whatever but like what the [__] and it's
like we are literally go people are
putting themselves into debt just to get
on a flight these days like it's so
expensive and we're literally being put
in danger I I don't know about this life
no we need to talk about the airlines
cuz if we don't who will it's
unacceptable I want to say like the
doorka airlines door the door should be
bolted then there was the other flight
where some dude was sitting in the exit
row and like looked out the window and
it looked like like the wing was like
fly like like falling off so he said oh
excuse me Mr flight attendant I feel
like the wing is maybe like not secure
turns out he was right they didn't take
off like what is going on what is going
on at Boeing and then did you see the
CEO he like went to Congress to answer
for his s and he was like we would not
put a plane in the air that we didn't
bro your door fell off yeah what about
the door and it's like we've been fly
flying airplanes isn't like new
technology but it's like they were doing
it better decades ago than they are now
like what's changed we need a full
investigation and I agree it's more
expensive than ever I'm we used to
complain like the price goes up the
quality goes down your sardines it's
so such like a torturous unpleasant it's
dang un luxurious experience but like
you arrived so yeah I was like Beyond
annoy that I then had to reroute an hour
sit on the charmac for an hour while
they like fixed whatever it was and then
fly back an hour it was a 3-hour like
delay and of course course I was annoyed
about that but I was also like concerned
about the safety of me and my fellow
passengers right and it was and then I
so thank god oh and of course this is
just the way the world works I'm like
all right I'll miss the first game I'll
miss the chief's game but I really was
like more concerned with the Niners game
and I'll just watch it on the plane of
course my flight didn't have Direct TV
like some Delta flights have access to
live TV and some don't of course mine
didn't and it just feels like back in
the day they all had live TV they did
and now we have less live TV but we're
supposed to be advancing as as a people
no we have less live TV like we have
Serious XM audio like who [__] cares
yeah so thank God for YouTube TV I was
able to watch and I have to give you
know credit where credit the Wi-Fi was
streamable and it was free so it was
excellent Wi-Fi I didn't have any
problems I was able to watch the whole
game but like what the [__] like giving
third world yeah like my God whatever so
I got home just in time for the ners
game but like me and my big plans and if
I had stuck with the original flight I
would have gotten home an hour earlier
right but you at least you made it home
same day for the Niners game which was
the game that was more important to you
until we saw what we saw by the way
don't you feel like okay so all the
girlies who were tuning in for football
last night like everybody was watching
for Taylor and Travis and of course we
tuned in and we were excited about that
too but like I was really excited for
the 49ers game and it's cuz I'm not like
other girls you know like all these
other girls who are tuning in just for
Taylor like I tune in for Taylor but
also for the love of the sport wow she's
one of those she's crossed over to the
dark side and I love to drink beer the
way that I felt watching the game
yesterday and I was watching with um
some other people I felt like I know
everything yeah there's nothing and I
know you guys like to say like we you
don't know I knew more than anyone else
I was the go-to source for information
did you see that Touchback in the Chiefs
game no I didn't oh well I I barely was
watching I was you know like eating and
with the kids and stuff but like it as
in as far as like the Dynamics at play
and like as far as the Dynamics yeah I
know everything well there was a
Touchback um called in the Chiefs game
which I kind of brought to light last
week right as this really dumb
controversial Rule and everyone was
messaging me like oh my God I know what
a Touchback is because of the toes so
like it's just people say we don't do
important work here and those people are
dumb and ugly yeah so let's get into the
stories because wait before we do
oh it's also worth noting that we did a
big merch shop on Friday and I'm so
happy everyone got their merch I wanted
to say the shop is still open so we're
going to be accepting orders for a
little bit longer there's two sets
available they're very sporty very
athletic one is great one is Navy I am
wearing a size medium Jackie wears a
medium/ large um and it's just a
fabulous merch drop that you can get at
shop toast merch.com it's kind of our
biggest merch drop to date I'm so
excited that everybody's loving like the
athletic Vibes we're doing yeah and I
you just love to see it you really do
get your threads shopto
merch.com now now without further Ado
it's time it is time for the fast five
stories that you need to know but really
just the one and the fast five stories
that you need to know but really just
the one are brought to you by the new
Lion's gate movie scrambled which is a
heartfelt yet hilarious journey of
self-discovery and self-love It Was
Written directed and stars Leah
mckendrick who is quote among Indie
wire's top female filmmakers to watch
this year I was watching the uh trailer
last week like not literally getting
teared up talk about a movie that's
talking about it's a real movie that
feels like a movie that's talking about
like a real issue for women like it's a
real thing women go through I feel like
it's a really relatable story so
quintessential Eternal bridesmaid Nelly
Robinson who's played by leam mckendrick
is constantly finding herself between
weddings baby showers bad dates so when
she begins to feel like the clock is
ticking she is faced with the Bleak
romantic prospects Nelly decides to
freeze her eggs setting her on an
empowering Journey To A Brave New World
where she ultimately discovers the one
she's looking for might just be herself
so film threat is calling it a brilliant
storytelling film and you can learn more
about it at liines gate.com mov
scrambled watch the trailer the music
was making me cry and it's just like
she's so much of the movie the trailer
is like her and her brother like her
brother is older than her no one's like
bothering him about having kids he's
literally going to have kids when he's
70 and she just like finds herself in
this moment where she's like oh my God
like if I don't have kids or if I don't
do something like I might not be able to
so it's a very relatable story it's in
theaters February 2nd it is rated R so
again the movie is called scrambled it's
a licap film and it is in theaters
February 2nd rated R today's episode is
also brought to you by Kaden Lane and
their new color me pajama sets which are
the kids these days latest obsessions so
Kaden Lane was started in 200 by a
single mom who wanted to create better
and cuter clothes accessory and
keepsakes for her own children and kayen
Lane is on a mission to make Mom's lives
easier they show that shows up in their
Color Me pajamas that help make bedtime
fun and enjoyable or hiding extra Zips
and snaps and outfits to make it easier
for moms to get their little ones
dressed you see the brands that go viral
you wonder if they're worth the hype
while Kaden Lane is absolutely worth the
hype they have over 70,000 festar
reviews and millions of customers for a
reason if I may please Kaden Lane is the
best pajama kids clothed baby brand it's
all I buy Every Time Charlie hits a new
age like I go to kayen Lane and I Reby
all the ones I had at the other size
because I love them so much they have
the cutest Prints but they're also just
the softest and you want to be putting
your baby in the softest things for
Charlie it's what he wears every single
day is you know footy pajamas but for
Harry those are the pajamas he wears to
sleep at night and I still want them to
be super soft so much so that Kaden Lane
is a new sponsor on the toast which is
so exciting but they wanted to gift us
stuff and I literally own everything
from their website already so I got some
like accessories which Harry also loves
silicon silicone toys of like pots pots
and pans and forks and like eating
utensils and stuff because that's the
only thing I didn't already own from
their site also it makes for the best
gift because they will personalize
anything just I literally owned
everything from the site already for the
from the last two years that I had to
find something I didn't already own
Kaden Lane also I'm sure you've seen the
meme if I could tell new mom's one tip
it's zippered pajamas zippered pajamas
don't bother with the buttons don't
bother with anything else Zi Zipp
pajamas and Kaden Lane has the zipper
that starts from the top and also the
zipper that starts from the bottom for
those just diaper changes in the middle
of the night you don't need anything
Lane Kaden Lane is your One-Stop shop
for all your newborn infant and toddler
apparel head to Caden lane.com toast and
use code toast for 20% off will order I
will be once again that's Kaden c a d n
l n.com back/ toast for 20% off and make
sure to use promo code toast so they
know that we sent you I will be using
that code thank you ler Deo you welcome
our first
story last night last night we let the
football talk so let's just like go in
chronological order you know okay that
seems like a good plan it's 3:00 we're
in Baltimore the Ravens led by Lamar
Jackson are taking on the Kansas City
Chiefs led by of course Patrick Mahomes
and Travis Kel and everyone's talking
about this game for a multitude of
reasons one I think people were like is
Taylor going to go of course she's going
to go I never even crossed my mind to
say is is Taylor going to storm the
field cuz of course she would never do
that like what's so funny is while we
were watching the game Zach was like do
you think Taylor's going to go on the
field and I was like no she can't like
it's a secure like no never what are you
saying D are you even paying attention
and then when I saw it on my phone I was
the first one to see it I was like she
went on the field okay so the game
itself was really it was heartbreaking
because this is my first time ever
watching a Baltimore Ravens game we've
been talking a lot about Lamar Jackson
he's like this Wonder kid y ya 80
million i' never seen it in action let
me tell you he's very talented extremely
talented the team is very good they have
great defense it was a it was a tough
loss it wasn't like it was this big you
know blowout loserville it was anyone's
game up until the end and I felt I felt
for the people of Baltimore I did
because I don't know maybe it was just
like I really like their color that that
Violet was nice like I just I was I was
kind of rooting for them a little bit I
was like go off Lamar that's how I felt
about the debt too I like their color
and I felt bad for their fans okay so I
have like a a hot take when we get to
debt but but I'll get there in a minute
cuz the Deb fans are giving Barbie movie
fans they just they're being really
sensitive and they're like like
seriously you guys celebrating like do
you know what we've been through it's
like relax it's football no for real I
kept having this realization and it's
like I'm so I'm so into sports you guys
like I'm here this is a sports podcast
like we're changing our whole business
we love sports I want to watch it all
the time I can't get enough but then I
like have this moment where I'm like
this is game no the Deb fans are being
really crazy like we play this in our
backyard and like the amount of hoopla
for a game and people the way they talk
about it it's you have to just like just
immerse yourself and not think about
that but they literally act as if it's
like a war life or death no and like
people were messaging me being like I
won't be able to tune in and like dead
serious by the way I won't be able to
tune into to the toast more like it's so
heartbreaking and I know the story of
the debt like and I and what they
accomplish is amazing like and what I
was saying to Ben last night cuz Ben was
like oh my God this really sucks um and
it does but you don't just like one year
get really good and win the Super Bowl
like it takes time and so they've never
even made it this far and so their time
is coming it's it is not their time but
the Deb's time is coming it doesn't just
happen in one year like this magical
thing what they did is amazing it's
historic they will get to the Super Bowl
in the next few years like this is the
start do you know how many years like
the last couple of years the 49ers lost
in the NFC championships lost the Super
Bowl like it takes time you build and
you build and you build and you will get
there the dead fans absolutely have to
calm down like you will get there it
will happen for you yeah back to
chronological order and if you can't
make peace with that just remember it's
a game and like we're just having fun
and we're getting we're getting overplay
paid to play a sport that you play as
children like it's so fun it's fun so
back to Baltimore it was a really tough
loss but of course you know and I did
say here on this show that the NFL of
course has a vested interest in getting
the Chiefs to the Super Bowl and I did
you know kind of share that conspiracy
theory about the ref who's notoriously
lenient on the awaya team and I watched
the game and I felt like it was fair I
have no I have no qualms about the NFL
being scripted a lot of people are like
the NFL is scripted of course the Chiefs
wanted to but I watched the game and
they won fair and square also the Chiefs
have been in four of the last five Super
Bowls like maybe they're just good right
now maybe Patrick and Travis and the
boys like are the best out there yeah no
like things are you know popular for
reason like they are good yeah they're
kind of how the Patriots were you
wouldn't say like it was a conspiracy to
get the Patriots to the Super Bowl every
time they went I I think people would
have said that by the way like back in
the day like they were saying that
really it was just Tom Brady yeah no it
was it's just Patrick Mahomes and by the
way four out of five Super Bowls he's
won four out of five Super Bowls and the
one that he lost was to Tom
Brady there you go so it was fabulous
the game was great and then Taylor took
to the field and absolutely no one was
expecting that
least of all me and we just got so much
footage we get and you know what we got
a lot from them comparative to her other
relationships like I feel like every
time we get a lot from them comparative
to any celebrity relationship because
she goes once a week and sees them and
then we also get in the rest of the week
we get a lot she's so generous so I feel
every time they step out together I'm
shocked by what they give us and last
night was absolutely no exception the
amount that we were given was
it was historic it was baffling it was
historic I feel like over the last I
know it's been 12 games because the
Super Bowl will be the 13th game she
attends yep I feel like she's become
really comfortable in the football
environment I think she really likes
most of the fans and the way that the
whole stadium treats her and the whole
organization that like by the time she
went onto the field last night like it's
a comfortable environment for her filled
with other huge stars and huge moments
that she doesn't feel so out of place I
completely agree I think like the league
and the coach and especially like the
Kansas City franchise has been very
welcoming to her now of course there's
like the moronic idiotic fans who like
burn pictures of her at tailgates I
don't think that stuff really gets her I
think I I agree with you like the league
at a very high level and the team at a
very high level like take care of her
and make her feel like family like
there's that picture going viral of Andy
Reid like pointing at her he's on stage
accepting the AFC champion and he's
pointing at Taylor I think she feels
like it's a real family I think she
feels safe and I think a lot of that has
to do with Travis making her feel really
comfortable who she is like I mean I
hate to always bring up the song Piece
but I think up until this point the song
Piece is a perfect example of how Taylor
felt about her Fame but also how it
would affect like her happiness
romantically and if you re if you listen
to the lyrics it's like kind of
devastating it's like a person coming to
grips with the fact like she'll never
really be you know in a relationship
that's comfortable and that's normal and
that is able to make do with her level
of Fame and here in comes this just like
big dope Travis who loves every minute
of it who I think has taken away like
every shred of insecurity she had about
like her being this sort of like
elephant in a room cuz he's an elephant
he's an elephant and he's Larger than
Life and no one's really bigger than her
but in so many ways he is and I it's I
saw that Meme that was like Taylor
singing piece and Travis just comes in
he's like ye dog he's
like no and you know what is he doesn't
have these internal conflicts that she's
worried about for so he's so
neurotypical he's neurotypical he's
confident and he's having fun and these
things should be fun remember we're
playing a game no at the end of the day
what it boils down to is like up until
Taylor met Travis like everything was
just so serious and Travis is this
deeply unserious person and I think it
took like this kind of like silly goofy
you know man to like make Taylor realize
like wait not everything is so dire I'm
literally like the most famous beautiful
woman talented in the world like I could
do whatever the [__] I want and she just
you know what if I just went on the
field what if I just had some fun what
if I did what I want and yeah what if I
went on the field and now her having
gone on the field it's like of course
she should have done that of course and
look how much fun she had like and she
would have that would have like would
have been a moment she robbed herself of
because she was like so you know nervous
about what people say or wanting to
protect this like deeply you know being
deep like deeply protective over
something she would have missed out and
as much as she has like security
concerns about going down to the field
if you actually think about it the field
is another safe place filled with only
players and their families the same
people she's been around for the last
few months like the only difference is
there's even more cameras but she's kind
of shered that concern and it's and I
think she said or people are speculating
she said in the video like I don't give
a [__] about all the cameras he said
like he clocked a camera yes and was
like act like not going to be super PDA
and then she said I don't give a [__]
and kissed him and by the way the lip
readers are working overtime cuz these
two and I I don't know why it's shocking
but they said like love you yeah they
did well good well multiple times good
no a serious relationship that started
over the summer and now it's February
like they should be in love this is on
track for their eventual marriage in the
words of Liz PE woods these two shall
wed yeah I don't see how they don't but
then what gets me every time and I was
watching the footage like
just ging over the whole thing but what
had me actually chuckling was his speech
yeah you got to fight for your right to
part we're going to Las Vegas Nevada and
I'm like how is this her boyfriend I
know like this is the woman who wrote
family that I chose now that I see your
brother as my brother cuz there's
robbers to the like the literal poet of
Our Generation like you could open any
Taylor Swift song even the most like
corny pop one and find the most like
literally Walt Whitman
level reference but do you think it's
more profound than you've got to fight
for your your right to party no he kind
of did fight for his right to party in
the game he fought hard and now he has
the right to party and I'm sorry like
anybody who's ever read any sort of
romance novel having to do with athletes
like and I'm currently reading one about
a hockey player so like I'm just kind of
envisioning like her being so tiny under
his like big shoulders I know he was
wearing padding but like still his like
elbows are bloody like literally he's
covered in dirt and blood and her just
being like so tiny with her red lipstick
like you couldn't Colleen Hoover could
never like you couldn't write a book
this romantic no you really couldn't and
what's crazy is she's not even she's
tall she's 6 foot yeah so he's just that
large it is a dream no it seriously was
so cute but the the speech was cracking
me up it no and like that's just I think
the the speech you're right is sort of
emblematic of what's going on here such
a deeply unserious positive happy Goofy
person with some someone who I feel like
especially like pandemic and then
folklore Evermore and then the breakup
with Joe for a few years was quite
morose no and I think feel like she
surrounds herself with like artistic
even not her boyfriends like Jack ant
off like artistic energy dark thoughtful
serious people y but not everything has
to be that way all the time I completely
agree it was too much to bear like and I
imagine if you're like one of these
people who's like oh Taylor Swift ruined
the NFL like last night was probably
like horrible for you because it's all
anyone's talking about yeah no I forgot
like we also got our Super Bowl teams
who cares who cares actually I care
because the 49ers and won get there
afterwards but like it was like I could
seriously I could do a 5 Hour podcast on
this like as much as there's so much to
say like I have no words you know
there's no hot take yep it's more so
just like processing our feelings yeah
speaking about the cultural significance
what we maybe think happened behind the
scenes and and
and just treasuring it behind the scenes
we know that Kylie and Jason were there
again I saw a bunch of pictures of them
in the suite so I feel like they're
getting along oh yeah and they're not
best friends they're not best friends
they should I don't think they need to
be or that they even should be because
that's just too much yep agreed Taylor
brought Kelly teller and car deline and
it's so funny how Kelly teller has
become like a Kansas City Chiefs like
girly at every game when her husband is
the biggest Eagles fan probably like a
bigger Eagles fan doesn't exist but I
actually don't think it's that much of a
conflict because now Kelly's hang out
with Jason who's the eagle it's not a
conflict but I wonder why he wasn't
there Chiefs fans can also be Eagles
fans if you're Kelsey fans that's true
unless they're in the Super Bowl against
one
another right the Kelsey
Bowl so um wait there was one more thing
I wanted to
say she was wearing the bracelet
everyone's quaking TNT oh yeah she wear
a diamond tennis bracelet that's like
made to look like a cheap friendship
bracelet but it's actually made of
diamonds cuz friendship bracelets is
just like how this whole thing started
with her and Travis and it says TNT
which people are saying St stands for
Taylor and Travis but n starts with an A
no I don't think that n is for n because
like you don't no not only would Taylor
never like most people would never
especially when you're setting it in
diamonds like right
n is that M for I don't
know me neither does he have a like a
puppy or something
oh the other thing I wanted to say was
another video that's going viral is
Taylor leaving the stadium with everyone
britty Mahomes all the Kelsey and
there's like fans outside and there's
literally like a [__] wench like a
literally being like Taylor a woman you
ruin football like screaming at a Taylor
and Taylor definitely hears and she goes
like this I love you so much love you
all but that's also because everybody
else who's waiting there like does love
Taylor so why would she do why would she
respond to the one wench no but like is
that wench for
real like like that's that's giving like
I care about football I'm not focusing
on the Wench I love that I will I refuse
and I think in general football has
brought so many couples together fathers
and daughters Taylor like it's all good
it's all and I was watching the game out
of my periphery yesterday and I didn't
see Taylor once and then the boys were
saying like no they showed her a few
times but not incessantly because I
didn't see her once it was not incessant
it was pretty much anytime Travis did
something big like a touchdown or a big
catch they pan to the person's friends
and family like why is that a big deal
that should be classic I want to see
what the friends and family have to say
oh and I feel bad that like this whole
recap you know we really haven't
mentioned Lamar Jackson because he did
such a good job and this was like my
first intro to Lamar Jackson and he um
is also going viral for throwing a you
know a ball like he does as the
quarterback and it got tipped off by
someone so it like flew the other way
and he caught it so he he caught the
ball that he threw did you see that I
heard heard about it it was me and Ben
were like we were like that was next
level like and that's he's a deeply
talented person and I felt bad cuz you
know he was playing really well and the
team was playing well like I have no
notes for them you know yeah the thing
is I feel like the Chiefs and the Ravens
were like better than all the other
conference teams but they have to play
each other here cuz the boys last night
were saying that the other conference
the 49ers conference like doesn't have a
great team well they have the Eagles and
the ners so that's not true well the
Eagles didn't go far so how great but
they were like they were supposed to and
the ners played amazing and Brock
everybody owes Brock an apology but they
have this like fatal flaw on the fact
that they don't have a franchise
quarterback yeah okay so let's get into
the second game now because it was so
fabulous and it was a true roller
coaster thiser they were down by 17
points at the half they could not get
arrested like not only could they not
score any points they couldn't stop the
other team from scoring points like it
was just bad it was 217 I think that was
the score or maybe 247 and
not to make everything about me but like
I never really do you call me like
feeling embarrassed I literally put on
my Instagram story I said I'm not
worried like I I know that like
something's going to happen in the
locker room they 49ers have that sort of
like you know Dylan Panthers energy
where it's like team camaraderie yeah
they're all really friends and family a
lot of them have been on the team for
many many years they're going to get in
that locker room and that Kyle Shanahan
is going to give give a speech you think
it was Kyle Shanahan I don't know who it
was actually I don't know who gives the
speeches a pastor on the payroll no I
feel like it's a teammate it's not
always who you think it like not Brock I
think it might have been like Kyle yek
because I think that's his role within
the team really is like he paternal yeah
and I I feel like he's a great friend to
everyone like everyone really respects
him that's why like that's the vibe I
get from Ling to Zach's shows like he's
a a fixture in the team kind of like a
Jason Kelce yep I know I love that yeah
yeah yeah and I just knew they were
going to pull it out and I literally put
on my Instagram people are freaking out
about it like I'm freaking out too but
it was just like people are freaking out
cuz at the half I was like do not worry
they're going to get a motivational
speech and the 49ers will win by three
they literally won by three that's like
a kind of a crazy call no yeah no pretty
crazy and now people are obviously like
saying that I am like involved with the
NFL in scripting the season which it's
just another liist Claim about me yeah
because if you were you wouldn't have
put it out there and you would have just
like placed bets quietly right although
you know last night did sort of negate
the entire super Super Bowl logo
conspiracy theory well yeah I feel like
we were on to them so they stopped you
know yeah no by the way for sure once
you catch on but would they have been so
obvious the NFL like by putting the
actual teams in the logo no I don't
think the NFL is scripted but I do think
with Taylor they have huge financial
incentive to get the Chiefs to the Super
Bowl but they didn't really even have to
do anything because the Chiefs gots
there maybe they they chose a favorable
ref but still if they were stinking they
couldn't get to the Super Bowl yeah and
I do think though that like it's just
getting them there I don't think they
need to win like I don't think it'll be
scripted I agree because even if she got
on the field and that would be a major
Moment Like The Views are in the show is
over so back to the 49ers game um and
the debt if I was the debt like the debt
is really mad at us like of course like
because we won and if I was the debt I
know we like love our coach because he's
just this like amazing guy with this
amazing story but like I feel as like a
football analyst the debt loss due to
poor coaching because there were two
times on fourth down when they should
have went for the kick gotten three
points and kept the lead up they went
for it on both fourth Downs to try and
like get another first down and they
lost both times they did not get a first
down either time that's two field goal
attempts that you like that's poor
coaching like I know it's you want to go
for it but you also have to be
conservative and also like play the
numbers and I felt like that was a big
mistake so so they made those two field
goals they would have won well if they
made either of them it would have just
been a different score and it would have
been like a one possession game versus a
two possession game like you know how
that works at like the last two minutes
with the three touchdowns like no
literally I don't know it was just I
think it was bad coaching and I know
everyone's going to come for my neck but
like sorry we love this guy Dan but I
think he made a mistake twice you can
make a mistake without being a bad coach
I think no I didn't say it was bad coach
I said it was bad coaching like it was
bad calls being made you said in the
beginning like you started kind of like
a referendum on
him no I know they love their coach all
yeah know all these two things can be
true you love your coach but like you
can be like I If I was a debt fan I
would blame the loss on the coaching who
coaches the coach ain't it good to be
the coach you know like if the coach
needs to train and become a better Coach
no I don't think like you if you get to
be that level like you don't need to be
trained could always improve like the
debt is like licking their wounds and as
they should like it sucks I totally get
it but like don't be mad at us for
winning like I think you had a very good
you were up by 20 points at one point
like you had a very good chance at
winning I think like your coach kind of
for lack of a better phrase you know
fumbled the ball I think you just
underestimated the
49ers no I don't think anybody
underestimated the 49ers when I was
watching the pregame with like grank and
Terry Bradshaw everyone was like Michael
Stan saying who they thought were
everyone said the ners like they are
just factually a better team
underestimated them in the sense that
you thought that you could win yeah but
I think you should go into every game
thinking you're going to win no yeah but
you thought that like you were going to
win I guess for a while you were winning
and you know Jared G was excellent a lot
of his you know receivers I feel like
that's maybe not the right word like it
wasn't Jared like Jared was throwing the
ball to the people the people were not
catching it there was like a thousand
fumbles also we need to talk about Brock
yeah everyone need owes Brock an apology
not us because we've been supporting him
all week and saying he deserves a little
bonus mhm and saying that he's doing his
best and his best is good good enough
right and you know him going to the
Super Bowl playing against Patrick
Mahomes who was a $500 million contract
when he's getting paid $800,000 he's
gonna drop the ball yeah it's really
crazy now as a matchup I like I I'm root
and people are like clut who are you
going to root for you love Taylor but
you're like I'm a 49ers fan like I'm
rooting for the 49ers but you know it's
not going to be bad if if the other team
wins like I won't be
devastated however like I need to you
know talk to ner Nation like how do we
win for real like how does Brock beat
Patrick Mahomes like for real he prays
on it he prays on it I love that I'm
roing for the 49ers because I wanted the
Chiefs in the Super Bowl so we can have
this moment Taylor running back from
Tokyo she by the way is going to the
Super Bowl she can make it she has ample
time I thought she landed 5:00 p.m. on
the day of the Super Bowl no she lands
500 P p.m. 500 p.m. Saturday the day
before she has 24 hours she get spa
treatments it's Vegas she could have go
out to dinner she has more than enough
time there's no reason why she shouldn't
be there she will be there like it's not
even a question right so I just like the
NFL I just needed Taylor at the Super
Bowl I don't need them to win same same
no I want field content maybe a onfield
proposal like Travis actually would do
something like
that honestly like I If okay he wouldn't
but actually you can't you know the
thing is you can't predict these two
like they have become so almost like in
a good way and I'm not meaning this
negative like Choy and Millennial and
public like I what if he just got down
on 18 and it would just be giving like
Romeo save me like I can't it's too much
he it's not out of the realm of
possibility that he would just do that
you can't put Travis in a box you can't
like even Taylor like the most powerful
woman in the world like he's so
unpredictable yeah like he could get up
on holding the Lombardi trophy and be
like Taylor he might even make a speech
and and talk about her oh my God that I
would like better
and he could also just maybe he didn't
even have it planned he could just be
like will you marry me and gives her his
super roll ring off his finger yeah he's
just like overcome overcome you can't
predict this man so when you say it like
that I kind of need them to win but
barring that wouldn't happen and it's
just we want her at the Super Bowl we
want to see all that I would want the
49ers to win it is their time they so
deserve it it is their time that's
what's most important like here it's
their time but it is it's not going to
be an easy game you know this matchup
like I think as I I couldn't even say
who's a better team like you kind of
have to hope that like the Chiefs have
an off game well not even the Chiefs
because I think the Chiefs are pretty
evenly matched the quarterbacks are
not but the Chiefs lost a lot of games
this season remember there was a time
where like them being out of in the
Super Bowl was out of the question yes
but it's like they got their [__]
together just in the nick of time where
it's like the like them and the Eagles
kind of had opposite experiences like
like the chiefs were like stinging it up
during the regular season and the Eagles
were like on track to just being number
one and then they just sort of kind of
had this sort of you know perpendicular
journey and it's like I feel like
football's all about like when you get
your [__] together as a team it's a
short season you know or I feel like
sometimes it's just not luck but like
The Vibes like The Vibes could be off
and so the energy I feel like for the
ners they have to play their best and
also hope that the Vibes are a little
off for the Chiefs
yeah yeah I know Brock is just Brock is
very you know Miss I'm going to be
honest like the first half was Miss
second half he was like [__] this and he
hit you know he had the power of Christ
with him it compelled that happens in
the Super Bowl though too he could have
a bad first half does the Super Bowl is
a religious experience as well and I
think what last night's game taught us
is that like it's never over no just
when you think it is it's not yeah that
was like that Super Bowl with the
Falcons and the
Patriots do you remember that one
remember I forget what year it was they
were winning like the Patriots were lost
and They just won no and that's what's
so fun about
football and like I always love the
Super Bowl cuz I love the commercials I
love the food I love The Vibes I love
like the memes and the Super Bowl
performer but this year I think might be
like my favorite Super Bowl yet yeah and
we're going to be together and we're
going to be together we're going to be
eating so much food like I think I'm
going to have to get like wasted like
I'm going to be like a brad like I think
I need to like start should we play beer
pong like I think we need to have like a
full-blown house party done like a frat
energy great yeah we could use the
backyard maybe like yeah oh my God I
forgot like you have a house yeah I have
the outdoor TV I just got my outdoor
furniture oh my God outdoor TV like
should we have like an outdoor and it's
not even that like hot in Florida right
now no we're having coldfront right now
like that's the vibe yeah put the hot
tub on like literally like a frat party
hot tub I haven't been in my hot tub
let's do it okay I have to figure out
how to work it I'm so excited like this
is just like not me being like a real
girl who loves football so sad that
there's not football on this week it's
the Pro Bowl but like who cares but
what's crazy is that Travis kely is
going to do a podcast this week he's
going to do a podcast this week oh and
then of course in the bye you know the
week before the Super Bowl it's the
Grammys Taylor Swift has been confirmed
to be attending of course she's
nominated for album of the year a lot of
people were like well if he loses he'll
be able to go with her I think if he
wants to go with her like like you said
Andy Reid they love her I do think
they'll give him one day off and like
they need a break you need to
rest because of the Super Bowl I don't
think he'll go but wait let me tell you
the Super Bowl is in Las Vegas him going
to La so they're training in Las Vegas
this week when did they no the team I
don't know when you go but you
definitely go early you have to do press
there's a lot of stuff like wait also
can we talk about how every commercial
on football is Patrick Mahomes and
Travis Kelce I imagine this year Travis
Kelce made more in brand deals than he
did from his Super Bowl contract I was
curious about the commercials too I felt
like every commercial is covid packs
loid and the fiser Jackie literally
experience Travis Kelce State Farm
Travis Kelce Subway Travis Kelce there
was two more I was shocked and a lot of
them have been on the whole season I'm
sure he got them at the beginning before
he started dating Taylor but I'm sure he
booked some more commercials I feel like
also when you're watching a Chief's game
oh fizer he's fizer for Mr fizer yeah
like so many commercials watch a Chief's
game they play the commercials with the
Chiefs players that's a good call it
would be smarketing smart marketing it
it's
and then maybe for the
ners debt game they don't really have
commercial guys so they just I feel like
George K is is commercial oh Christian
mcaffrey he's in commercials no not
saying that they aren't they shouldn't
be but are they in commercials maybe I
Christian mcaffrey I feel like he is
this is also his first Super Bowl
Christians yeah no and like you know the
Olivia Copo of at all the CH do you
think Christian use will make an outfit
for Britney Mahomes or Taylor Swift even
though they're like competitors I do yes
because I think it's like the women's I
think it's a good message reminds
everyone like this is a game we're
having fun we can all support one
another and she has two weeks now to
make a bunch of outfit and I think
Kristen should make something for
tailored that way confirmed like we got
a SLE outfit yeah and Kristen's like
sort of signature look is these puffer
jackets um but it's in Vegas so she
might have to do like a coret she's also
big known for corsets and miniskirts
right but she's only been doing the puff
because it's been freezing oh that's
true actually but and that's like what
she went viral for right but she's
usually does like a corset or an
oversized tea or a pant or a jacket she
could do anything yeah yeah I'm looking
forward to seeing what she wears too
what everyone wears yeah we kind of need
a red carpet No and there are so many
like events leading up to the Super Bowl
like parties for the and especially
because it's in Vegas it's going to be
like even bigger and better big clubs
but there aren't like real red carpet
moments at the Super Bowl and there
really needs to be there needs to be
like a full televised we need E news we
we need Tanya rad and Justin like there
we need a red carpet and then when the
Wags like walk into the stadium they
just walk that carpet it doesn't have to
be like this whole thing but we just
need a camera on them and when the
players walk they get like the full
Hollywood treatment we see all their
outfits it's like a big fashion show
obviously Travis is known for like his
killer outfits we need that for the
women we do like foot sorry football's
for everybody now and we need you know
equal pay and it would be a red carpet
which is great cuz both teams are red oh
so who wears what color
well and they're both kind of like red
and yellow one team like in the Super
Bowl someone is considered like the home
team also they did play each other in
2020 so we could just look back at those
picks yeah yeah
rematch no there's a lot of history here
it's going to be an amazing Super Bowl I
cannot wait good luck to everyone go
ners bang bang woohoo any other thoughts
no I mean like so many they're just
pouring out of me I'm sure they'll
continue to pour out for the rest of the
show but and the rest of the week also
the airlines with their 1989 flights and
80s flight 87 going from Kansas City to
Las Vegas like just keep the door on the
plane yeah I guess just keep the door on
good I guess it's like a thing whenever
they find out who's going to the Super
Bowl Airlines will add flights from that
town makes sense and now they're like
being kitchy and cute with their
marketing like it's flight number 1989
uh keep the doors on and go get a drill
and screw the bolts in and shut up just
make it there safely please and thank
you why don't you bring the fans alive
that would be nice bring the fans alive
why don't you deliver all the fans in a
live why don't you bring all the fans in
a lively manner all cell phones stay on
the plane yeah like why don't we ju what
if you just did your job yeah don't
worry about the flight number don't
worry about it no don't worry like
you'll have your moment haha cute like
1989 like haha just do do we all have a
role to play in the Super Bowl to come
and yours is just getting the fans there
safely yours is just safety just no and
travel necessity it's not about the
numbers and the Taylor Swift you have no
part of the Taylor Swift uh fandom I'm
sorry no it's like sit the [__] down and
shut the [__] up like Get out no one
wants you just fly the
plane
yeah yeah oh it's just too much it's
really too much and the Las Vegas
stadium is like the sickest Stadium um
and I'm sure Taylor will have like the
best possible Suite I know they have
like on field sweets they have like
these crazy like on field sweets yeah
I'm curious where she's going to set I
wonder who she'll bring with her this is
like the cream of the crop it the season
started and she was I was actually
noticing this because I was picking
stories and Sophie was going to every
game cuz like Sophie was going through
it but now Sophie and her mans are very
serious she posted on Instagram with him
they've been on the ski trip and I feel
like Sophie's kind of flown the coupe
yep unless car green is going to the
Super Bowl so I agree I think it'll be
like the at team and I do think that
includes Kelly I do think Blake and Ryan
will be there like they really started
this journey with her they but they
mostly stay in the games near their
house oh that's true I don't think
they'll be there maybe her La friends
but also Taylor's kind of become a part
of like this Chief's family she doesn't
need a million life rafts no she doesn't
so like she's got Britney all of
Travis's friends who like seem to be
recurring characters cuz I start
recognize them recognizing them more and
more and she keeps hugging them and
stuff she doesn't need that many like
friends yeah but if I was her close
friend I would want to go like it's a
fun thing the Super Bowl not even
because of her but like everyone wants
to go to the Super Bowl I I read the
cheapest ticket is going for like
$99,000 well that's the other thing is
that I do think even Taylor Swift like
you have to be prudent those sweets are
hard to come by they've been purchased
for a long time she obviously can get a
site but like I am sure everyone's
family Donna and everyone wants to go
you can't bring a million friends like I
think Taylor's probably and I'm sure
Taylor's like footing the bill for the
suite or maybe Travis's I don't know cuz
it's like his family too but she can't
bring 55 people because it's Donna it's
Jason it's Kylie it's Travis's friends
like it's a lot of people so Taylor
could probably bring like two to three
friends yeah no you're right I don't
think there will be more she has to be
conservative I don't think there will be
more than one Chief
site right for Travis so it's need to
bring only right no I think there will
be more than one Chief Suite but Travis
and Patrick are definitely going to have
one suweet together and so that includes
Patrick's mom brother sister kids like
it's a lot of people
yeah what's the brother's name Jackson I
thought it was Justin because I'm so
hung up on Austin Mahomes yeah yeah I
was going to say you think it's Austin I
need Patrick and Britney to have a son
named Austin just to close Circle yeah
it's funny that would be that would be
important to me and I'm just like
continuing my journey loving Britney
Mahomes like it's just it's all good you
know but her and tailored were not
together yesterday yes they were oh they
were both in the suite yeah got it I
didn't see they arrived together they
left together it was all good oh Jackie
she seized on it it's
true take your time you sick yeah I for
the last few days I've just been like
had a tickle in my throat and now today
I'm sneezing and I have no idea where
it's come from no one around me is
sick spooky scary I have chills just
like not ideal should we like continue
on with the stories even though it just
feels so irrelevant how long have we
been going 47 minutes oh my God okay
we'll we'll give you the other four
because like that's a really crazy
precedent to set like what story has to
be big enough that it's the only story
if there ever was a story like it would
be that but listen we have a job to do
and we will do the other four we will do
the other four but swiftly like Taylor
Swift for lack of a better word yeah
we're going to be swift about it okay um
anything else that you want to say
before I get into the stories no I mean
like we have four we have time like not
if we're going swiftly oh okay I guess
then the swiftly stories are brought to
you by Taylor Farms so Taylor Farms
chopped salad kits deliver the freshest
best tasting salads to eat at home or on
the go across North America Taylor Farms
is a family-owned company on a mission
to create healthy lives throughout fresh
delicious food Taylor Farms chop salad
kits they AI boring in every bag with
over 30 flavors each base is a unique
blend of greens and veggies created to
perfectly complement the toppings and
dressings to the best tasting flavor for
flavor forward salad kits so they really
are where convenience meat freshness the
salads are pre-washed pre-cut and ready
to enjoy whether you're busy
professional or a Home Chef Taylor Farms
salads make healthy eating a breeze like
salad bags are so fabulous but let me
tell you some of these brands are out
here with like crusty Dusty musty salad
bags Taylor Farms is so fresh they have
such great different like flavors and
KPS and it's really so genius to always
have in your fridge like whether you're
busy or you're just like hungry it's
just a great thing to have they so so
amazing I feel like I always want like a
big juicy salad but I don't have the
time or chopping prowess to get chopping
or the creativity and they it's done
it's done with Tor Farms so with my new
with my new like healthy chef kitchen
Vibe these easy salad kits are the
perfect healthy and flavorful addition
um whether you want to have it as a meal
or just you know a little side maybe
make some rice some chicken whatever it
is so purchase Taylor Farm's Cho salad
kits where you like to shop it's
available at all major grocery stores
and next time you're going for salad in
a bag like the only real option here is
Farms I'm sorry like it's fresh it's
good it's really Innovative with their
flavors and their different kits and I
love it kits today's episode is also
brought to you by Caraway as you're
starting the new year do you have any
goals that Caraway can help you with
because one of my goals is to stop
ordering in so much and carway has just
been absolutely instrumental in that
goal for a lot of people they want to
stop ordering in to save money they want
to stop ordering in to be a little bit
more Health forward whatever it is
caroway can help you with so many
collections to explore there's sure to
be a carway for every kind of cook their
internet famous kitchen wear is a staple
of any home and it comes in a variety of
modern Shades to fit with any design
aesthetic you can ditch the chemicals
with carway their non-toxic cookware
features a chemical free ceramic coating
so food can be prepared with peace of
mind that no hardto pronounce chemicals
will leech into your healthy ingredients
all of their sets come equipped with
complimentary easy access storage
solutions to keep the kitchen tidy their
colors are so gorgy I just got the new
Sage set I couldn't be happier with it
I'm going for like a new green undertone
Vibe very Olive in my new home I've got
like green Furniture I've got some green
rugs and having the green Co we really
ties the whole thing in together and of
course it's just like it's the best pan
easy ceramic coating nothing sticks easy
to clean five star you know don't make
me insult your intelligence by like
bragging it's non-toxic it's easy
cooking and it's well- loved over 65,000
people have rated five stars about their
Caraway kitchen so now it's time to try
for yourself visit carway home.com
toasty to take advantage of this limited
time offer of 10% off your next purchase
this deal is exclusive for our listeners
so visit Caraway home.com toast or use
code toasty t o a s y checkout caway
it's non-toxic non-toxic cookware made
Modern thank you that made me hungry our
next story like really the next four
just I feel I honestly feel sorry for
them I do too um Kim Kardashian is set
to produce and feature in an upcoming
three-part BBC documentary about
Elizabeth Taylor oh my God who cares
yeah Kim is gearing up to produce and
feature in BBC's upcoming three-part
documentary covering the life of
Elizabeth t
Kim was actually the last person to
interview the late movie star before her
death in March 2011 and what what you
know Kim's obsessed with her I didn't
know that oh yeah she's like bought some
of her jewelry that's gone to auction I
like Kim buys everything like you know
yeah but like this is like someone who
is just you know like her
Kim okay so she's going to produce the
documentary and also feature in it which
I wonder in what sense maybe talking
about their final interview yeah I mean
this is just like another like part in
Kim's Journey just wanting to be some
sort of like
Hollywood uh mover and Shaker well yes
but this is a documentary and I do
understand it's just like another notch
in her belt though like for yeah
production like she's a producer now
yeah uh but no this makes like more
sense to me than you know her starring
in a Netflix series right like a romcom
but it'll be interesting I wonder what
their last interiew
was
yeah story is not storying for me yeah
well having a hard time like gring up
like a [__] to give you know yeah well
there are people like Elizabeth Taylor
She's a lot of people like Marilyn
Monroe Audrey he like she's everything
jewi you might want to know that she has
a documentary coming out you know what I
that's probably a documentary I would
watch I don't know a lot about Elizabeth
Taylor but I know she's like a Jewish
Ally Queen and she's like uh Evelyn Hugo
right right right right so like I would
watch this yeah me too she's someone
that I don't know a lot about that like
I would want to get into her story this
seems like Good Portal and then you
would end up like reading a book written
by like a hairdresser or something love
can't wait yeah love that for me yeah
that journey is coming up for you are
you ready for our next story yes our
next story is for the co-s sleeping
masas because Adrien bone is talking
about how she turned her son's room into
a playroom since they co- sleep she said
oh wow okay by the way I don't know if
we ever talked about this on the main
show because you said it on the patreon
yeah and I'm not co- sleeping anymore
but for the first four months of
Charlie's life we were co- sleeping
exclusively and Jackie just said like
[__] it like [__] it and the thing is I
think a lot of people co- sleeping gets
like a really like bad in secret there
was literally a cut article called are
we all co- sleeping and just lying about
it because it's like not textbook safe
sleep it's it can be dangerous but a lot
of what I read is that most Coast
sleeping accidents happen when you fall
asleep accidentally and you're not
prepared like when you go to sleep
intentionally knowing you're going to co
sleep there's a lot of things that you
could do to make it
safer when there have been Co sleeping
accidents it's from people who didn't
plan to fall asleep got it so that's
just something to know but anyways yeah
a lot of people [__] Co sleep and
it's great okay but accidents happen you
guys when ACD happen you have to be safe
about it you know don't use a blanket
you have to be sleeping in a safe
position like you need to do a little
bit research on what's best but it's
also so innate like the idea that you
have to do research for this like
Natural Instinct but just be safe about
it if you're curious okay anyways Adrian
byone her son is 17 months and he's
still sleeping in bed with her so much
so that she turned his what was supposed
to be his bedroom into a playroom she
was on The Tamarind Hall Show and she
said the reality is we co-sleep so we
don't call it his bedroom anymore that
bed is there for when my cousins come
over and they got kids they sleep in
that room that boy is in that bed with
me I'm not letting him go I just want to
say like I before I go to bed tonight
like will pray for Adrien balon's like
DMS because people are so nuts about
this topic like it's a personal choice
however anyone chooses to parent like is
their journey and people get so and
literally people were when Jackie said
she was Co sleeping on the patreon
people were like I'm canceling my
patreon like okay yeah co- sleeping is
pretty controversial but like it's like
anything else more personal than some
babies go to sleep in the crib and sleep
great from day one if that's not your
reality like trying to and you need to
sleep like I feel like the first three
months of Charlie's life the only reason
why I was functioning was because I was
getting decent sleep because we were
sleeping together right like what's more
dangerous co-sleeping or having a mother
who's not awake yeah no it's just and
every baby's different some babies just
don't want to go into the crib yet but
now but you could also you don't have to
go sleep till they're 17 months but she
talks about how her journey to having
her baby was a very long road they did
ibf I think she had a surrogate and so
she said I'm not letting him go he
sleeping with me that's that on that but
I think when your baby gets bigger the
bigger they get uh well it becomes more
danger Dangerous less danger of you
rolling onto them more danger of them
rolling themselves off the bed oh oh oh
but you could put up things like there
are things that you could do yeah yeah
yeah but yeah when your baby 17 months
like it's kind of just like having a kid
in your bed yeah no it's like annoying
no it's like they're a person they can
sleep it's not like as dangerous as
sleeping with like a newborn like I one
time in my life I have been so blessed
to have Harry fall asleep in my bed like
I don't know what happened it must have
just been like a crazy day or something
we he was allowed to come into bed with
me and watch a movie and maybe it was
boring cuz he fell asleep and let me
tell you I've thought of nothing else
but that moment since like it was the
most magical thing that's ever happened
to me I felt special I felt Chosen and
if I could do that every night like [__]
it yeah I'm doing it yeah no it's it's
really really nice again not for
everyone but for the this is stories for
those of you who do it because for
everyone else you know your pediatrition
tells you AAP you're doing great
sleeping on the back whatever for the
people who sounds so simple and you're
co-sleeping
like I see you now when you go to the
pediatrician like do you admit it or you
lie well that's that's like in the
culture and I found like some co-s
sleepy Instagram accounts where like
people talk about these things and it's
like everyone we dread going cuz it's
but did you lie I don't lie okay cuz I'm
not a liar and what did the doctor say
like you're not even for like uh
accident purposes but she was just like
more so you want to get him out and into
his own room or else you'll never be
able to and I'm someone who I want that
eventually Independence like I'm not
going to have the them sleeping in my
bed forever like some people who want
that but she was more so like if you
want him to eventually sleep in a crib
outside of your room like now you want
him Now's the Time at 3 months and I'm
like okay maybe five months right right
right oh that's funny okay yeah but what
I felt like he was is more ready and
also able to put himself to sleep you
know whatever works whatever yeah
whatever works but her advice wasn't
wrong in the sense that like if you want
it to happen eventually like you can't
go on forever like this of course of
course but less about the like that's
bad don't do it right yeah cuz like I
know I see of course you know the AAP
always with their guidelines that change
every day and then they're like oh the
last one don't listen to that one this
one's the real one this is yeah
oh that's the AAP they're like remember
when we said that thing don't listen to
us it's this no Dem lado is like my last
documentary I was lying the whole time
this documentary is my real
truth classic okay it's like happen like
three documentaries in a row classic
stuff that's how I feel about a lot of
baby guidelines that have changed so
every 10 years they change and it's the
opposite of what they said 10 years ago
so just do what you think is best right
so I'm like so what are you going to say
10 years from now what about what you're
saying now isn't correct no so that's
why it's just like do what you think is
best go with your gut maternal instinct
is real maternal instinct is real even
though there was an article that said
maternal instinct is not real who wrote
that article slanderous it was like New
York Times e who wrote the article let
me call them by their name I just don't
believe that like at all no I don't
believe that at all but they say it's
like a social construct which is oh
that's such a lie is such a lie instinct
is not
real I'm going to go with Washington
Post the New York Times claims that
maternal instinct is a misogynistic myth
wait why is it misogynistic it literally
gives women magical powers literally but
I guess I don't even want to theorize as
to the other side I don't want to I
don't want to platform this dumb idea I
don't want to platform
any rationalizations that would make
people think that maternal instinct is
not a real thing it's real it's real are
you ready for our next story yes some
neelon news because suits has beat the
office in streaming record for 2023
neelen reveals their original streaming
shows shut out of yearly top 10 it's all
rewatches and that suits has beat the
office which is like that's really big
okay but just for this one year not like
in total streams oh of course not but
for this year okay that's what I thought
you were saying at first but that is
crazy yeah so oh I hate when they rack
up minutes watched like but also is the
office bigger than friends yeah so I
need to go um to the list of the top 10
but didn't say the office was number one
but just said suits beat the office so
that's
insane yeah I wonder if any of the
actors because most of the actors from
that show like aren't like popular
working actors right now it was like
that show is kind of like their big
Roman Empire and I wonder if it's caused
any of them to like book more roles I
feel like it would CU they all do like
Indie stuff like but are any of them
going to be in something we've actually
like going to say it would be nice yeah
and what they really should do is bring
suits back on Netflix like Arrested
Development Vibes but make it good
that's actually a great idea but Megan
Marco wouldn't return you never know
actually if there was ever anything she
was going to return to like these are
people she knows she's really close with
like no she wouldn't have returned three
years ago she wouldn't have returned two
years ago maybe in a year from now yeah
you know things are winding down over at
archwell archetypes Productions they're
looking for new content maybe archet
maybe she would insist being a producer
on the show right right right getting
like a back door deal make it all look
like it was her idea love wait what was
the story oh that it beat the office in
streaming records right and um ited 57.7
billion total minutes watched whatever
that means office was 57.1 billion total
minutes watched now I guess like if I
had to guess prior to this story like
what's the biggest sh show of all time
like currently like that people still
watch like I guess I would say the
office but I don't know why I find that
shocking just cuz we don't watch it
right right but like I would have thrown
like Seinfeld friends in there like
they're all very same on the streamers
it's on Netflix friends is on Max people
don't I feel like people don't rewatch
Seinfeld in the way that like as a
comfort show in the way that they
rewatch friends I'm sure some people do
but not like hordes the way friends or
the office yeah cuz not even it's not
even rewatching people just have friends
and the office on as like background
noise for them these days it's like a
comfort show it's just like sound it's
not even a rewatch yeah I'm trying to
find the list of top 10 the way they're
making this so difficult to decipher new
and final season of young Sheldon
premieres like this
month sad no and I think I know what
happens what cuz it's a show that's a
prequel so like apparently there's like
this big thing that happens in big
Sheldon's life and people are assuming
that like that is what happens now I'm
sure that would and now that I know what
it is like I'm I really don't want to
watch I didn't
finish the seasons that are out there
but it's like it's always there for you
it's always there for me but I was
like I wasn't comfortable when I was
watching it and so like I have that
association with it like I was so
massive on this uncomfortable couch
right like deep into my PR like it was
just I need to a bad Association it's
okay I need to get good associations
though because I I liked the show but I
just like all of a sudden one day I was
like I can't do this anymore maybe when
I come down like we'll all watch it
together and have a giggle and like
that'll be your new Association yeah
yeah I just I had to call a lid on young
child No Cap No Cap she you had to put a
cap on it I did Fifth and final story
yes 118 new emojis are arriving to your
IO 17.4 including a lime a shaking head
and four gender neutral
families so we also have a Phoenix
Rising a brown mushroom a broken metal
chain two shaking heads for gender
neutral families and there's also a 100
people facing sideways in a range of
skin colors and genders including some
holding canes and others in
wheelchairs I just feel like it's going
to get really hard to find the emoji
that you need like when they're doing
brown mushrooms like there really
doesn't need to be Emoji for everything
no but it's so crazy that you can have
all these emojis and still not be able
to have red head everyone oh oh they
don't still no like I couldn't do a
pregnant red head oh that's crazy I
could do a pregnant man the thing is is
like
you the thing is is like I do think it's
futile for Apple to try and really
include every single person no they're
they're they will not they're going to
die trying because at the end of the day
like everyone is different like people
keep changing and also it's like if we
do red hair variant then like do we do
blue
hair well but red hair is natural
nobody's BN blue hair I agree but maybe
that's the argument they would make but
that argument doesn't even work for the
iOS operators because they're like yeah
then we'll do it I don't give a [__]
We'll add it yeah no no no the thing is
is like I just I do feel feel like it's
a a fruitless Endeavor there on cuz
every year they add more things but
every year people in the culture look
different and act different and identify
different they'll never stop trying no
Jackie it's it's it literally is like
The Song That Never Ends like it's a
hamster wheel they will never complete
what they've set out to complete but I
think they're okay with that and I would
be okay with it too if they would just
[__] add the redhead variant and
people will say there's a redhead emoji
and they send me the one I'm not asking
for a redhead Emoji I'm asking for every
single Emoji of person to have the
redhead variant right because they do BL
for every person you can select blonde
brunette skin color change skin tone but
you're right there is no redhead redhead
variant is what I'm saying yeah no I
know what you're saying so until you
guys add that you're never going to be
inclusive and you're never going to
accomplish your dreams of inclusivity
you know that right yeah that's like odd
though because they they go to like the
most sort of extreme and random they
like oh if there's one person in society
who's like this then they shall be
included right but there's you know a
whole culture of redheads it's a natural
thing right it's not like then going
into hair Dy which would be a whole box
to open up Bo box
yeah but maybe they could you know cross
that bridge when they decide I just
personally like I feel exhausted for
these people like it's just it's like
it's never enough but I also feel like
there's so many emojis that I go to use
and they don't exist yes yes yes cuz I
remember and I think maybe they've added
it but I was shocked to find there was
no bubble Emoji bubbles like blowing
bubbles I think there is now there is
now but you're right it's always like
these random things remember when they
changed like the gun to water gun like
that
helped we're on pece like I feel like
they're always like doing the most like
trying to keep up with every movement
and I I just want to say like I feel
tired for them like it must be
exhausting that department of Apple yeah
I'm tired for them but I also personally
like I have beef with them you have a
vested interest yeah I have beef like
I'm angry Shannon was just saying cuz
she came to New York she's was talking
about she's doing a trip to New York to
do like a bunch of bridal stuff and she
wanted to put like a redhead bride and
there wasn't no redhead bride
yeah excuse me it ain't right like what
is that no it's almost like Steve Jobs
like was seriously like betrayed by a
woman with red hair it's like the
company has a policy 100% except it's
like not Apple it's um this company that
does the Emojis Unicode Unicode the CEO
of unicode's wife left him for a redhead
yeah and he's never been the same s and
he will IGN not acknowledge redheads I
guess it's better than doing like a
busted redhe head yeah I mean none of
the Emojis are like particularly
gorgeous you know no but they they are
nice I'm also like not an emoji user
like I can't explain it I kind of hate
emojis low key sometime I like the
emotic con the yellow circles the
expressive faces the OG like No And even
some of the newer ones like the one
that's smiling and crying I'm I'm saying
OG in the sense of like the yellow
circles yellow circles but even the
updated yellow circles and they they
have like cringe Emoji of salute I love
them all I agree with that those ones I
use actually let me go to my most used
emojis what do you got mine are like the
ones we use for toast you know oh yeah
yeah yeah but like what else oh I use
hearts of every color oh I love this one
I love this I think it's hand Hearts I
think hand Hearts is a beautiful Emoji I
do the vomiting one like all the time I
don't know why oh that's good I have
crying with a smile but I also have
teary eyes with a smile I also have the
two fingers like pointing at each other
oh that's good I don't have that I have
oh the one that's like blushing and
surrounded by three hearts love that one
you love that you love that I love the
one that's like screaming in pain I'm
going to text it to you that's
like okay hold on texted it you I use
that all the time oh Jack the one she's
talking about is the one where like the
mouth is turned kind of upside down it's
like you know and you know I love the
one that's like like yikes the yikes
that's the cringe one I'm going to
screenshot this and post it to my
Instagram but why do I have your
favorite
emojis I have a rocket cuz ICI to the
Moon Yeah cuz you're always talking
about Elon classic oh the headphones for
listen tap to listen oh I always have
have the microphone in the camera tap to
listen tap to watch oh I use my
headphones that's funny um so yes best
of luck in this fruitless Endeavor Apple
we wish you all the best and that is our
show really you know the one big story
the four littles but I had a good time I
had a good time with the Ford Littles I
feel like we got actually into some
interesting combo yeah and I'm looking
forward to doing it all again
tomorrow same except you know with less
less exciting things in which to discuss
I don't know who knows the day is Young
that's true and New Heights will come
out this week right so that's our show
you guys thank you so much for listening
to the toast Morning Show where we deliv
the fast stories you need to know every
Monday Friday on YouTu so for watching
us on YouTube please subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so Spotify public radio
rast box all the places listen to
podcast find beautiful standing and
wickedly talented we
are love you bye love you
bye